so I'll do my meditation and I'll
Journal so it's like another form of
meditation and it's not like I'm writing
any philosophy like if you read my
journey what the this guy's
like today I'm going to
yeah that's not really what I'm writing
it's the fact that the act of sitting
down writing out the day yeah um
contemplating yeah hey today I'm gonna
you know I got training at this time I'm
really big focus on this you know set my
intentions on certain training sessions
I also don't drink coffee for the first
hour you should look up huberman man a
lot of things you're talking about he
pushes super hard he's been on Rogan
yeah I know of him but sometimes these
two says too much like too much for my
focus the light onto your neural retina
and onto those melanopsin intrinsically
photosensitive ganglion cells then we
get through that